Okay.
What's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday.
Fucking,
uh,
May 22nd.
Is that a record for how quickly I said the f word?
Uh,
I'm actually doing the podcast right now,
riding in a car.
I'm not driving.
I'm on my way to New York City,
cause I have to do some emotional stuff here for a second.
If it's for family that's coming out I this week,
right?
Or next week,
May 30th,
I don't know what,
so this begins,
oh,
Billy red face,
uh,
shown his freckled puts on anything I can get myself on.
Um,
you know,
so whatever.
I'm driving to New York and you know something,
there's all this fucking traffic and I got to take an early flight tomorrow back
to La.
I don't have time.
And my wife just sent me this whole thing on what successful people do and they,
they,
they fucking,
you know,
they,
uh,
I don't know what they do.
They,
they,
they know how many minutes are in a day.
Evidently there's 1,440 minutes in a day and they use this wisely and they
delegate,
right?
They delegate shit.
Like,
I don't want to do that.
You know how to do that.
Right.
All right,
I'll pay you to do that.
You know,
a small portion of what the fuck I'm making.
I got to get better at that.
In order to delegate though what you have to be,
she have to be social and uh,
you know,
that's not my thing.
And I said I had a couple of drinks.
Other than that,
I'm kind of a curmudgeon.
I don't know if you've noticed.
I'm a little bit grumpy,
but a fucking cruise it now with all the traffic of now watching,
this will be like a Thursday when I was going to get to do the whole hour.
Um,
so anyways,
I just got back from
my tour up there in Canada,
work with Nate Kraig who murdered it.
If you don't believe me,
ask anybody who was in Winnipeg,
Saskatoon and uh,
Regina.
And,
uh,
first of all,
I'm very proud that Nate and I did a show two shows in Regina and neither one of
us went with the easy joke.
No,
we did the stupid,
it rhymes with fun.
Nobody's like vagina,
Vagina.
What's up with that?
I thought there was going to be a giant Twat here.
Sinkhole flash thing.
We uh,
kind of left it alone and um,
I don't know.
We had a great time for it.
Let's,
let's just back it up here.
Okay.
We start off in Winnipeg and I told the people that Winnipeg,
that I wasn't going to tell people this,
but I just think they're so off the beaten path.
It's fine.
The cuisine in Winnipeg,
it's fucking insane.
All right.
Jesus.
What's the,
what's the name of that place?
We actually,
I didn't have time to go this time.
I,
uh,
ordered from this place.
The peasants something or other was my little list of places to go scrolling
down.
So when a peg,
yeah,
but those can be a bunch of traffic.
He's just blocking
me up.
The driver.
Yeah.
Alright.
Peasant Kitchen.
Get to torchy air,
if you've ever,
they had t,
O,
r,
t,
I e r e gets French,
pork pie.
And uh,
then we went to the tallest poppy for breakfast the next day.
And um,
I wouldn't have known about either one of those.
Shout out to a Canadian by the name of Ed Robertson.
You might've heard of him plays in a band.
I think he's in a garage band or something like that.
You might've heard of him.
I don't know.
I'm just fucking with you.
Um,
so anyways,
uh,
the food,
it was unbelievable up there.
And uh,
the shows were awesome.
Played in this old theater and I forget the name of,
I don't remember.
It's been around since like 1900 and up top.
They have like the same old shitty seats they used to have back when everything
was segregated,
you know,
and all the white people were downstairs in anybody else had to walk all the
flights of stairs to go upstairs,
you know?
And what's the result?
What's the result have 50 years later,
why people are getting their asses kicked in sports.
You know why we got no quads,
we don't have any glutes.
It's why our acids is so flat.
We just used to walk into the theater where you're on the ground level and
everybody else had to walk up.
Right.
It's why we get our asses kicked from the grid iron to the Dojo stroke.
It all comes back to going to see Harry Houdini and not having to work for it.
Um,
so we were actually there and it wasn't cold as shit like last time.
And uh,
you know,
try out some new stuff.
Everything was going great.
Um,
went to bed the first night,
didn't have a drop of booze.
How about that?
Huh?
Didn't smoke a cigar even though there was Cuban cigars,
but you know,
it's Canada,
so they got Cuban cigars,
but there's no place to smoke.
Uh,
they're very,
uh,
they're very hostile against smokers or they just maybe like over the
protective,
they sorta helicopter parent with smokers up there in the,
you're sort of,
I guess,
allowed to do it outside.
Although I did not,
I didn't think I really saw anybody smoking anywhere.
Uh,
so anyways,
we did that Gig and um,
the next one on the docket was we drove up to SAS Saskatoon.
Oh,
speaking of which,
there was these two or three concept,
the Winnipeg show.
I thought they were booing me,
but they were just going to,
I don't know why we were in Winnipeg.
I guess that's short for Saskatoon for like Cleveland,
the land up there,
I guess they call it the tune or they just yell out tune.
I have no fucking idea.
But we,
uh,
I thought they were boring me.
So you know,
I got off stage and I was just like,
Jesus Christ,
man.
I thought that was a good show,
you know?
Uh,
but I,
he's like,
no,
no.
They were yelling tune and like,
what's too,
and they was four for Saskatoon as like,
all right,
we're in Winnipeg.
They're like,
Oh yes,
sorry,
sorry.
It's a big thing in Canada.
Everybody,
sorry,
I'm so sorry.
Like this waitress was clear in our table then,
you know,
plate is empty.
And when she goes to clear what she goes,
oh,
sorry,
sorry.
It's like you're apologizing for,
do you brought food domain?
Now you're taking it away and you're apologizing all the time.
Sorry.
I'm sorry.
Get the puck out.
Sorry.
Um,
so anyways,
we did the drive up from,
uh,
from wedding peg to Saskatoon,
the one that everybody was saying,
hey,
getting ready at the hills and stuff.
Jesus,
that's not pleasant is it?
I'm sorry.
Sorry.
I picked it up.
I'm going to be ridiculously pleasant on this,
you know,
fuck those cons.
Who yelled at tune in?
Winnepeg sorry.
MMM.
So it was,
everyone was saying I was going to be dreading that drive,
you know,
like an eight hour drive.
And uh,
so we start,
me and Nate started driving up and we're just hitting all these bugs and shit.
But I gotta tell you,
man,
it was beautiful and,
uh,
both love the drive,
you know,
we live in La were just smashed in with a zillion other people.
It's nice to get out there.
What a beautiful country.
Canada is.
Good Lord.
Um,
all these,
these farmhouses,
all of this land.
It was beautiful.
No,
I just kept thinking it was,
I would love to fly a helicopter out here cause if he had a problem he could
land it anywhere as opposed to when I'm in la I'm looking for fucking soccer
fields and playgrounds and opened his not kids there.
If I ever had a problem and I'm just stuck,
there was just like just wide open spaces and I wasn't that bad a drive.
We didn't like seven hours.
We took the one lane highway instead of the two lane highway.
So we had a lot of fun like peeking around trucks and shit trying to pass them a
lot of farmers like driving these giant tractors down the fucking street,
you know.
Um,
I dunno,
I,
I got a bunch of pictures of shit that I saw every,
like every mile there were though,
there was a barn that looked like it was going to fall down and there'd be some
guy who just had like a zillion fucking cars
or tires or something all piled up in his yard.
It was really a,
it was pretty interesting.
And I was just thinking those guys from gas monkey,
you know,
if they ever pull all the fucking cars out of barns down in the states,
they could just go up to Manitoba and Saskatchewan.
They'd find,
I saw a number,
I saw a 65,
uh,
I'm driving like 70 miles an hour or two and I still saw it.
So 65 Ford Galaxy,
I don't know if it was the 500 might,
might've been,
I think it was a 64,
actually,
64.
I know.
I sound like the fucking rain man and I didn't right now.
So anyways,
and then we get up to fucking Saskatchewan,
Saskatoon.
And uh,
we only had one show that night.
So of course I went out and got absolutely fucking hammered,
hammered at this bar,
a lot of tattoos by tattoos up in Saskatoon.
Lot of tattoos,
sorry.
MMM.
But it was a town and had this amazing park and um,
which I forget the fucking name of,
and I got up the next day cause I,
and I show him all those years of have a paper route.
Like,
I can only sleep for so fucking long.
I just sort of naturally wake up.
So you know,
I didn't get to bed till like two in the morning.
I still woke up at like eight 30 and I was staying at that.
They're fucking a red rum hotel there.
It's this beautiful old hotel that looks like you could have shot the shining in
there and uh,
it's right next to this long park and it just was watching.
It gets a little mini waterfall.
They watch these pelicans trying to fish.
I saw some geese for some baby geese walking around was crazy.
Through all these years of living in New York and La,
I was just sitting there geeking out and there was some old lady standing there
looking at the goose,
that goose,
it's like putting his fucking head down,
looking at her and I'm thinking that's like an aggressive posture.
So I s I walked away,
but I was also looking sort of laughing,
like thinking that goose was going to fuck the old lady up and then thinking
like,
what would I do?
Because that would be bad.
I mean,
I can't walk away from the Old Lady,
but I also don't want to slap the shit out of this goose in front of all of its
children.
So,
uh,
sort of a tense little moment there out in nature.
And now,
fortunately,
cooler heads prevailed and everybody went their separate ways.
But the,
I don't think old lady knew how close she came.
You know,
she had a big grin on her face as the thing was like ducking down low.
So she's kind of ducking down,
like imitating it.
Um,
you know,
like she's looking at a gorilla and she's pounding a chest and I thought for
half a second that guy was going to see some like,
you know,
some fucking old lady bird MMA action,
you know?
Um,
but you know what?
She's so fucking older,
but she knows how to kill a goose.
It's probably went out in the backyard and I can do that shit.
They just walk up and they grab it by the neck and then they do the spin move
and then they just hold on to the next of the body spins and it just breaks the
fucking things and neck.
Um,
she looked like she was old enough that she actually lived during those times,
you know,
back when you earned your meal,
like you knew the name of the thing that you killed.
It was like a pet,
right?
And weird dreams and probably slipped into you'd fucking sexuality somehow.
You like dressing up like a bird when you fuck or something like that is some
weird thing with anytime you get abused,
you know,
filing sexy,
I don't know what it is,
it ends up making you some Weirdo in the wreck.
Um,
so anyways,
I ended up doing,
so I walked up,
I went over that hump,
that river there,
whatever the fuck it is,
like walking along these train tracks and I gotta be honest with you,
I was a little nervous about that because it was this old kind of wooden bridge.
And I was just thinking,
uh,
every time someone would walk by me,
you know,
I always kind of made eye contact and like brace myself because I just was
nervous that someone's just going to grab my legs and throw me over.
Never seen a movie a long time ago with this guy did that.
He was a psycho and he went with these people.
They didn't realize he was a psycho.
I think he already killed people and then he went up there and uh,
he went to like take a picture of this woman,
this couple have somebody push both of them off the fucking cliff.
Um,
and it was so eerily done that I'm like,
this has to be based on a,
on a true story.
Cause usually that's not good enough for Hollywood,
has to be some dramatic way.
They kill you rather than just some creepy real way.
Um,
so I was walking across that and that beautiful nature and everything.
Then I was just,
you know,
worried someone's gonna just,
I dunno,
just grabbed me by my ankles and tossed me right over before I realized what it
was going on.
You know,
typical shit had to be so busy trying to save my cell phone.
I would even think about myself before I went over.
I think I could have landed in dog,
you know,
I don't think I was that high up.
MMM.
What does that say about me then?
I'm going through nature and I'm thinking birds.
They're going to tack old ladies or somebody's gonna throw me off a bit.
Uh,
maybe we just don't fully conscious cause I know the fucking driver's listened
to here.
Um,
anyways,
plowing ahead here.
Uh,
and we did the drive down to Regina and I don't know,
I don't really have any,
we went to some fucking bar.
Well,
I don't even know where the hell I was drinking.
That's the same place I had lunch and I fucking went into when I was in
Saskatoon,
it's right,
right out front from the,
uh,
from the red rum in that I was staying at.
And Oh my God,
that place was a shit show.
And this is fucking hilarious.
We walked into the bar and the guy goes,
can I see your driver's license?
I go,
yeah.
And then he goes to scan the thing and I like blocked it with my hand.
I go,
do,
don't scan my id,
we're going to go on.
You know,
it's just for us but me.
What the fuck you mean?
Fuck Outta here.
He was scanned Nate stuff.
It's just like,
I like just the liberties that people take with your Id.
I don't let go of my id anymore.
Let me see your id and I just show,
I hold onto when they go to take it as this,
should I go?
Just read it.
I don't give people my id.
You can look at it,
you can read it.
MMM.
You know,
I check into hotels.
They always go to grab it from me and I hold onto it
the whole,
sorry,
sorry.
Can I say it?
I go,
I don't want you to type any information
into your,
uh,
you know,
oh,
we just do that.
So the next time you stay and now you don't,
you take it and then you sell it and then someone else gets it.
And then all my fucking shit's out there.
And next thing you know,
you know,
I don't know what somebody defaults on a house and fucking Regina and the banks
are coming after me.
I don't know why.
I just know it's not a good thing.
So,
um,
we went in there,
oh my God,
those people were fucking party.
It was a,
it was some sort of holiday weekend up there.
I don't know what it was for,
but a lot of tattoos,
lots of tattoos,
a lot of sleeves,
Lotta fucking tattoos.
And uh,
I just kept drinking and drinking and drinking and I vaguely remember bringing a
hockey stick over.
It was a Sherwood that blew my mind because I had not seen one of those since I
was a kid,
you know,
and they did shots out of it.
And,
uh,
I don't really remember much after that.
I just spent it.
I walked out by myself.
I do remember that,
I think.
Yes.
And then the next day I woke up and I did the whole stupid watch.
And when I was done with the walk,
there was this little double decker bus
and I was starving.
I didn't know whether it was a good breakfast place.
I just said fuck it.
And I walked up to the double decker bus that they turn into this fucking little
restaurant thing and I had a hot dog for breakfast at followed it up with a a
mint chocolate chip ice cream counter.
And I sat alone on a fucking park bench eating an ice cream cone at Saskatoon.
Saskatchewan
hung over as shit.
It just laughing at myself,
like what kind of a fucking life on my living.
So as I'm sitting there,
this nice Canadian,
a
couple pulls up,
right?
They bolt on bicycles,
one of them is towing a kid and I just see the one guy,
you know,
they're all like Flanders.
That's how nice they are up to.
And he just goes,
he pulls up and he's like,
oh no.
Oh No.
And I'm like,
what's he looking at?
And I turned around and I looked back the,
you know,
the little bus thing that they had the hot dogs in the ice cream and like 40
children's jet just showed up,
brought up by like the teachers or something.
It's like they were going to be out of ice cream and hot dogs by the time these
people loader.
It was fucking hilarious.
I beat the rush just by like 30 seconds,
but like they were just all know.
Oh Geez.
Well I guess we got here at the wrong time.
No,
no,
no.
Sorry.
It's okay.
It's all going to keep you eat everything.
I don't need nourishment.
They were like even apologetic like dead.
It was so
I always forget how loud and obnoxious I am and my fellow Americans are until I
go to like other countries,
like I don't want to be the guys shit,
not Americans,
because I was up there and they just kept talking about how nice the people are
up there and I was like,
dude,
fuck these people.
They,
they've riot when they,
when they lose,
you know,
a playoff series.
Okay.
They just as racist.
It just as fucked up,
blah,
blah.
By the time we got to Regina,
I was like,
all right.
You know what?
These are really nice people.
I'll give it to you.
All right.
I'm stubborn.
I don't want to be yet another person that travels to another country and then
it comes back here to tell everybody how everything in this country is wrong.
You should see how they make a grilled cheese sandwich up there.
I mean,
it's just so good.
Like everything's like fucking better.
It's like really?
Is that why everybody's always paying attention to us?
You know,
if we stink so bad,
how come you know the name of our president and we don't know the name of your
president.
I want you to think about that one for a second.
G I don't know bill,
cause you guys dropped bombs on us.
All right,
fair enough.
17 minutes.
This is like the fucking old days
right now.
If you'd like to know I'm going over the Manhattan bridge.
MMM.
Looking at my old digs way back in the day up to street.
I used to live in Yorkville.
I think that's what it was called and it was rows of the depressing fucking
Roosevelt Island Queensboro bridge.
I walked across that they one time I was so sick of going to the gym.
I was just like,
you know,
I ran down,
I didn't run from the,
and I fucking walked down,
walked over the bridge.
And there's no way to walk on a bridge and not think about that Saturday night
fever,
the fucking idiot.
You know?
I love how he was too cowardly to get into that fight.
And then he's going to do a headstand on the Verrazano Bridge.
That's still,
by the way,
that's the one in,
Nah,
that goes from Brooklyn to a stat now and see if I still remember this.
It Goes Brooklyn Bridge,
Manhattan,
Williamsburg,
then Manhattan.
Hey Sir.
Is this the,
uh,
Brooklyn,
I mean system Manhattan Know Williamsburg,
Williamsburg now,
sorry.
William Spark my fault.
So it goes Brooklyn,
Manhattan,
Williamsburg Borough,
and then I don't know what the fuck else is up there.
There's some sort of foot bridge
Triborough bridge or some shit.
They probably renamed it,
you know,
at this point,
it's not the Jackie Robinson fucking bridge.
It's probably be named after some,
some lady,
you know,
I dunno what some lady you fucking showed a claim on a show and she was
considered brave.
You know the Harry Twat,
every bridge snug they get.
I don't do what?
Fucking vagina.
Joker,
Vagina.
Now I'm going to do it.
Had on a,
on a bridge.
What's wrong with me?
Um,
so anyways,
oh my God.
Alphabet city.
Yay.
Now it's like all Nice Tompkins Square Park.
All the memories are coming back.
You know,
I've been gone from this city for so long that there's a lot of it that I don't
even recognize it.
Like,
I mean obviously the empire state building and that type of Shit Times Square
and that type of thing,
but it's like just a completely different from the city that I moved to.
Like Times Square was fucking scary when I moved here.
So we just drove by,
just drove by as it was driving like 30 miles an hour with the sunroof open with
their cell phone out the top video tape.
I guess I'm podcasting,
but I'm not driving right?
Or do you want to film it all?
I'm sorry.
Sorry.
It's okay.
Um,
I'll edit it for you.
I won't charge you anything.
I'm Canadian.
Um,
how funny is it that they're that nice and then you get them out on the ice.
That's when it all comes out.
Right.
Fucking crosschecking to the neck.
I was at Flanders,
gets his glasses off,
puts on a kind of sweater and you better keep your fucking head up.
That's Canada,
right?
You please do a drawing of fucking Flanders as fuck
the fucking,
I don't know,
the Thunderbay Lamas,
whatever,
whatever the name of your teams are up down the fucking
lower levels,
the minor leagues,
whatever you call every fucking Canadians as say,
oh,
I made it the thunder bay and the,
I didn't,
I wasn't good enough to get the NHL.
So I tried to fight my way into the lake.
I know I'm doing a bad Canadian accent.
I apologize.
But uh,
yeah.
Anyways,
what,
whatever.
To what I remember long time ago,
Jeff Ross hosted a comedy show live from Tompkins Square Park.
And I remember thinking that was so fucking bad ass.
Anybody that was performing there cause alphabet.
See like before you even came here,
people were saying how scary that was in like Thompson Square was just like the
city had just given into like,
I mean it was like as a subway going by fee or something.
Um,
it was just like a tent city.
Like I walked by at one time and it was just like,
uh,
just trying to mask the fear on my face plus,
you know,
rubber neck and just wanted to see what it looked like.
And uh,
it was like junkies,
homeless people just fucking mentally ill people.
It was like,
it was like the beginning of a bad like hair metal video,
you know,
when they used to try to do those apocalypse once,
they were all basically loosely based on the escape from New York.
People coming up on a man holes even what's his face did that Michael Jackson
did.
It will look like it was like the thrill of video except uh,
you know,
it was real
get away.
Um,
anyways,
I'm going to read some advertising here at the risk of getting car sick.
MMM.
It was funny about having a kid.
Is your screen savers all become your kid.
And every time you pick up your phone,
you just,
you know,
you were around other adults and they have no idea.
You're looking at your kid and you just go ball.
Then you try to turn it into a cough.
Excuse me.
Cause he's a man.
You're not allowed to show love.
Um,
all right,
content live reads.
Okay,
here we go.
Ah,
look at this.
Look at this.
Live from the fucking Williamsburg Bridge.
It's old zip
recruiter.
It was driver's gonna.
Think I'm nuts.
Uh,
are you hiring well,
are you,
do you know where to post your job to find the best candidates?
Talk about the challenge of finding great talent and,
or the approach importance of finding great talent
to a successful business.
But I think people know that.
Yeah,
yeah,
you can't,
you guys didn't know.
You know,
when you're hiring people,
you don't want to fucking moron that come in,
especially if they're running the register,
you know,
or your new CEO,
you don't want to dope.
You want the best person possible.
So be nice.
If you could,
you could pick from,
you know,
hundreds of thousands of people rather than whatever mouth breather answers your
ad in the local paper.
Uh,
how's zip recruiter is different with sip?
You can post your job to 100 plus job sites with just one click.
Then their powerful technology efficiently matches the right people to your job
better than anyone else.
That's why ZipRecruiter is different.
Unlike other job sites,
zip
doesn't depend on candidates finding you.
That one was creepy.
That was like a ghost went by.
It finds them.
In fact,
over 80% of jobs posted on ZipRecruiter get a qualified candidate in just 24
hours.
That's how great this is.
And that's how desperate people are.
No juggling emails or calls to your office.
Simply screen rate,
nice tits and manage candidates all in one place with ZipRecruiter's.
Easy to use dashboard,
call to action.
Find out today why zip
has been used by all businesses of all sizes to find the most qualified
candidates with immediate results.
And right now my listeners can post jobs on Ziprecruiter for free.
That's right.
For free.
Oh,
that's right.
For free.
Sorry,
would drive it.
Sorry.
Uh,
just go to ziprecruiter.com/bird that's ziprecruiter.com/bar one more time.
Hey,
try it for free.
Go to [inaudible]
fork in recruiter.com/burp sorry,
that was my bad New York accent.
A,
I'm zip recruiter.
No Way.
All right.
Car Shield.
I have no idea what this is.
Is this a bra for the front of your car so you don't get rocks up on it?
Uh,
sooner or later your car will break down.
It's a fact.
Every car,
truck and SUV owner knows if you're lucky.
It happens while still under the manufacturer.
Manufacturers warranty and the repairs are covered.
If it happens after the warranty expires,
you could be out of pocket thousands to get it fixed.
That's why getting extended coverage from car,
she'll dot com is a good idea.
A new engine or new transmission could cost over $5,000.
Transmission doesn't cost $5,000.
All right?
You can go on youtube to figure it out.
A fucking pull an engine.
You could do it.
Uh,
even as simple repair to have sensor Cenk cost.
Over a thousand dollars skip that hassle man.
Car Shield makes the whole process like dead Canadian hope cross processes.
Sorry,
easy.
You select your favorite mechanic or you can even go to the dealership to do the
work.
That's cool.
And there's no checks in the mail stuff or waiting for reimbursement car.
She'll gets the mechanic paid directly.
Car Shields administrators even give you VIP treatment providing 24 seven
roadside assistance and a rental car while your yours is in the shop so you're
not left stranded out in the cold or you guys could maintain the fucking
engines.
It's fun.
The engine blocks made out of fucking steal salsa transmission.
If you just keep it looped up.
I mean theoretically it gets last forever,
but who knows?
Who's kidding,
who.
You're not going to fucking do that.
Are you?
So get cars,
shield.
If your car is three to 12 years old,
it doesn't mean you have to pay high repair bill.
Bill's car shield administrators have paid out close to 2 billion in claims and
they're ready to help you.
Save yourself thousands and potential car repairs.
Get covered by the ultimate and extended vehicle service protection before it's
too late.
Visit car shield.com/burr to save 10% that's cars,
shield.com/burr to save 10% of a deductible may apply in a bunch of other shit.
Be careful with those guys,
man.
There's always some fucking thing there.
Extended warranties,
maybe they're the good guys.
All right.
Upside.
How many more of these goddamn things are there?
Two more.
Two more than I can start people watching like I used to do back in the Danes
shitting all over,
buddy.
All right.
There's a better way for you to buy business travel.
It's called upside.com every time you buy a trip it upside.
I'm just reading as fast so I get through it.
You'll save your company a ton of money and they give you Amazon,
Amazon gift card worth hundreds of dollars upside upsides,
able to do this because they bundle your flights and hotel together for one low
price bundling pricing saves money.
God dammit.
If you're a frequent business traveler,
you're company saves a ton of money and you get thousands of dollars a year in
gift cards just to go,
how many hookers you can get when you fly over to Thailand just for buying your
air and hotel together at upside.
Plus you still get all your miles,
man.
If you're shopping for business travel,
you'd be crazy not to check out upside.com crazy.
I don't know about crazy but you know,
probably foolish.
It takes just three minutes to see how much you can save by buying your flights
and hotel together for one low price.
And right now you can use my name or your and you're guaranteed to get at least
a $100 trip.
100 I'm sorry,
$100 trip.
You know fucking burger king,
$100 Amazon gift card for your first trip.
That's my name.
Bur Bur to get at least $100 Amazon gift card.
Save big on travel and get a big gift card every trip.
Um,
evidently I love upside.com even though I'd never used an upside.com minimum
purchase required.
See for complete details.
All right,
here we are.
Graffiti,
graffiti,
New York.
Somebody wrote Elvis for some goddamn reason,
or let me get some New Yorkers here.
Where are they?
Oh,
we got a red light.
All right.
stamps.com everybody.
I use stamps.com just I'm coming off the bridge,
by the way.
All right,
coming off the bridge.
I use stamps.com to send out anytime a worn myself out to send out my posters.
Stamps saves you time and money,
which you can use that time to help grow your business.
I can mail any letter,
any package using just my computer and printer and the mailman picks it up.
Avoid the hassle,
man of post office and mail everything from postcards to envelopes to packages,
domestic or international.
Create your stamps account in minutes online with no equipment to lease and no
longterm commitments.
Click print mail and you'd done unlike the post office stamps.com never closes.
Print postage for you letters or packages at your convenience.
24,
seven,
seven days a week.
Uh,
keywords to describe it or any bed.
Evidently it convenient,
easy,
reliable,
flexible,
dirty ass.
New York.
Look at these fucking people.
Oh my God.
Kids playing outside in New York on supervised little kid acting like he had a
gun and this is like the Old New York.
I know this is going to be all like fucking high end.
No,
it's not so crazy guy.
That's an artist.
Who's he talking to himself?
Robin's sold gold.
Cash
by gold isn't only Asian looking woman.
They're leaning up against a dirty poll.
The Fuck I Essex Street and de Lancie
never used to be down here.
Alright,
convenient,
easy,
reliable,
flexible.
Right now you can enjoy the stamps services with a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus postage and a digital scale without longterm commitments.
Go to stamps.com click on the microphone,
top of the homepage and type in burpee.
You are that stamps.com enter bar stamps.com never go to the post office again.
MMM.
All right.
Down here,
like around house to the street.
Back in the day I used to do this fucking room called surf reality and uh,
it was the beginning of the AllSeen and the level of talent.
This was before you could start your career,
start a privileged career in the fucking old rooms where there was like no
heckling,
let's just support and give somebody at least 20 minutes to get to a fucking
punchline.
This was like club comics going down there and then just some Weirdo people
that,
you know,
just what,
just totally different.
But all the comics loved them.
And I used to do a place down here called surf reality.
I remember every time I got off the train and I walked over here,
I used to fuck,
I was convinced I was going to get mugged and uh,
I bought this jacket from the army navy store and a black fucking hat trying to
look like I was in nom or some shit.
And uh,
you know,
keeping my head down.
So they didn't see the fucking Ron Howard look on my God damn face,
you know?
MMM.
You know what's great about this is as I look out this,
I might be able to do a whole podcast and not bring up what is happening to my
Boston Celtics,
Jesus Christ.
Everything that I feared finally happened.
I told you guys when we first started watching him,
I'm like,
how could a team that doesn't really have a center that doesn't rebound is not
good playing d and the paint and lives and dies by the three?
How can you win in the NBA?
But they did and I bought into it.
And you know what a big bucket of reality hit us in the,
gave us the old right there,
Fred.
I don't know if game three is tonight,
but after watching game to Jesus Christ,
I was,
I was so excited.
I forgot the number one pick.
Next year I'm going to go out on a limb and say,
maybe we should get a center.
Where are you guys second man,
you still believe Kelly Olynyk.
If the rest of the team can somehow get us to game seven,
I'm warning you people in Cleveland Right now,
you better watch out for Kelly Olynyk.
That is a bad man and games seven games one through six,
he's fucking horrific.
But you get that man to game seven,
lucky seven.
That's how I,
that's what I call lucky seven with this Colby 11th brings to Celtics to have
and some shit.
I don't know if it rhymes.
It's true.
Um,
I don't know after game too,
I'm wondering if we're even going to make it to game four.
I mean,
we lost by 54 fucking points.
That's like some shit that happens when you're like in middle school.
MMM.
But his,
there's a part of me that actually enjoys this because,
mmm.
I'm rooting against the warriors and I think it bugs Lebron and the Cavaliers
that we were the number one seed,
I think it bugs him that they acted like we even remotely had a shot against
them.
And I know Isaiah is hard.
We just found that out.
But come on,
he's hurt.
So what we only lose by 34 points.
Um,
I think they just got a chip on his shoulder,
did the defending champs and nobody is talking about them like they are and
everybody's up the fucking ass.
You know the old,
the Boston Celtics who they are number one seat just trying to,
well the series,
right.
And everybody's out there talking about the fucking,
the filthy golden state warriors kicking people in the balls and blowing out
fucking ankles and shit.
Um,
okay.
I mean has there been a more boring western conference or Eastern conference?
Matchups I mean these things have just been absolute blowouts.
I bet they call an upstart again and he's going to get those mobbed up reps in
that it fucking start fixing some games again just so they don't lose out on all
this ad money cause these things are just going to go,
they're going to go for games rather than having 14 games possibly of ad money.
They're going to have the bare minimal eight,
you know,
and these owners,
man,
they got a lot of money they have to pay out to these players.
You know,
they spend a lot of money with their hookers and all that type of shit,
you know,
near fucking tummies tucked lap band surgery and all the ship getting their
faces yanked back so they can keep banging the underpaid cheerleaders or
whatever it is that they do.
So everybody,
I've,
everybody's just basically waiting for the finals and um,
I don't know,
man.
I don't want to jinx it.
I'm going to shut up cause I already jinxed the fucking city of Washington
by just saying I don't want to jinx it.
But,
uh,
I think,
I'm not gonna say what's going to happen.
I'm just saying what I would love to see.
I want to see the Cavaliers win.
I want to see them go fucking back to back.
And I want to see that fucking Dream Team of a,
I dunno,
I can't say a bunch of free agents.
Just,
I don't know.
I've just all country because I wanted to see the fucking,
I wanted to see the thunder,
see if they could get by him.
I didn't want to see the fucking one of their best guys just join them.
God Damn team.
Um,
can you imagine it like back in the day,
you know,
like when Larry Bird steals the ball from Isaiah can imagines the next year,
like Isaiah Thomas was a Celtic then we just kicked the shit is a fucking guy
staring at me.
Like why I'm doing this recording right now.
I just waved down and he continued to stare at me and now I'm feeling like now
I'm feeling weird.
Oh,
I guess he was looking at the car.
It's sunglasses on Jesus Christ.
It's this guy.
A fucking robot.
And why is he looking at me?
He's got a minivan and he just stay.
I'm in a SUV,
I guess if you have a minivan,
you fucking,
you take your sunglasses off to look at an SUV.
Right?
The minivan is sort of the ball,
his SUV
and the SUV sorta the one ball like a,
I don't know,
full size truck.
I don't know how it works.
I'm not a redneck.
I'll fuck day.
The Handmaid's tale on Hulu.
So anybody watching that.
I came home the other day and my mother in law,
she always,
she watches all these shows that I would never see.
She started to watch one about,
it was about this girl who committed suicide and left like a tape and she was
watching that one.
Now it's like it's like little house in the prairie meats,
like an s and m video.
It was really weird.
I don't know what was going on.
Like they would,
they would make these nuns and they were trying to escape this thing and one of
them makes it on the subway and the other one doesn't and then next thing you
know they've got her tied down and they're beaten her feet.
How do you get that job?
You official like feet beat her.
I could see like back in the day,
you know what I mean?
Back in the,
well maybe this was not this.
What seems to be like in the future,
do you realize that there's people out there that they're born in at some point
when they try to figure out like what am I good at?
Like the answer to that ends up being torturing other human beings have fucked
up,
isn't it?
You know what I mean?
Just like,
it's kind of like being like a comedian either funny or you're not.
You can't teach somebody to be funny.
And then there's like the like torture and stuff.
You just can't teach somebody to be able to do that and just like block it out
as somebody fucking screaming this site.
He was sitting there screaming and crying.
The guys just,
just whacking the shit out of her feet.
I always come always as my alarm.
Like Jesus is kind of what the fuck,
what the hell are you watch?
And she always laughs,
he's like,
I don't know,
I just put this on.
All right,
so here we are.
Jesus Christ.
You know,
I got to give it up to the graffiti artists.
Like they've really taken it to another level
know
and certain tattoos I've noticed,
you know,
there's like that the high level tattoo artists are amazing.
But the problem is is most people that get tattoos,
uh,
don't have a lot of money.
So like,
you know what's the worst is when you see somebody going to a tattoo parlor and
they're looking at shit on the wall and it's just like,
dude,
that's going to be in your body for life.
You don't even have like a,
you don't have an idea,
you don't have a theme
and see a,
I don't know,
kind of like a butterfly with like a B.
And that's what's gonna end up happening.
If you look on a wall,
it's either going to be a skull.
What sets star Tattoo that everybody has that red and fucking black one.
I know like three comedians that have them and a couple of boyband guys have
him.
I don't know what it is.
Maybe it's an anime thing.
I have no idea.
That's my new word enemy.
Cause I'm watching that fucking one punch man.
Uh,
anyways,
let's get back to the Celtics.
Holy fucking shit.
You realize we have lost,
I think
we've lost by like a total of like,
like north of 80 points and the first two games definitely north of 70.
Like,
if you took all the,
if you just had the Cavaliers win by one end game one and then one in game two
and you just gave him all those other points,
like they would not,
they could have me in there.
But whose kid know me?
You got me in there for about a quarter and a half.
It's all tired up 78 78.
Uh,
Jesus Christ.
I mean this is like one,
this is the worst beating a Celtic team has ever taken in my life in the
playoffs.
Uh,
the other,
the other closest,
most humiliating one to this was,
I don't know if a lot of people don't remember this during the Larry Bird era,
and it was the last year of Bill Fitch.
She'd kind of lost the team.
I guess they blame the coach.
I don't know how,
but we got swept by the Milwaukee Bucks and I remember we lost game one and we
lost game two and then we lost game three and I just kept thinking like,
they're going to turn it on,
they're going to turn it on.
And then they lost game four.
And that team had Larry Byrd,
Robert Parish,
Kevin Mchale.
Uh,
I don't think we had Dennis Johnson at that point.
And I'm trying to remember who was on the box.
It was Sidney Moncrief.
I Dunno who else.
Um,
dude,
I'm so psyched that I already got 40 minutes of this fucking podcast done cause
I have no god damn time.
Like I was supposed to beat this thing that I'm doing.
I was supposed to be there 25 minutes ago.
It's five 55.
It's supposed to start at six 30.
So there's some pa right now freaking the fuck out.
And um,
there's nothing I can do about it.
I'll go there.
Someone House the street,
the fire engine.
And this is just like the fire chief has got like a pickup truck.
MMM.
Oh,
they've got a fire engineer,
by the way,
dude.
You see that fucking lunatic,
which is plowed into the,
uh,
all those people in Times Square.
What the fuck is wrong with people,
Jason?
I didn't want to like talk about it to give anybody fucking ideas.
Let's get off that subject.
Oh,
the Adidas store.
I love Adidas.
I've always been an Adidas guy.
I don't mind Nike,
you know,
I like it.
I was like the Adidas better.
You know why?
Because no one knew.
Like everyone knew Adidas before Nike came along.
If it's Nike,
Nike,
I don't know what it is.
Oh Wow.
Look at this.
This is down near the old fucking
I.
Oh,
subway stop.
When I used to live on the upper east side and I used to come down and go to the
comedy cellar and the Boston Comedy Club,
Astor place,
that's what I used to get off.
And that's when he started looking up all the names of these people.
Like who is it?
What is Astor place?
And I found out about the aster family and you get,
they just all,
just a bunch of fucking slum lords,
all the statues.
I just started looking them up,
learned about the triangle shirtwaist fire
people jump into their fucking deaths because somebody's locked the door to the,
uh,
look that one up the triangle.
Shirtwaist fire actually read a book on it.
And uh,
it was just,
I don't know why.
I did.
It was,
it was the most uncomfortable book since I read,
I read the book,
the perfect storm.
And um,
if you don't want to buy the book,
just fucking open it up and just,
there's a chapter,
maybe like a three page thing maybe where the guy describes what happens when
you drown and it's just like,
I don't know how you fucking blood goes cold man.
It's fucking freaky.
So
do you know ever they find those guys in the caves,
they always had this goofy smile on their face.
Like those divers decided to fucking swim into a damn cave.
Then what I love,
they're dumb enough to do that.
And then some poor bastard has to go in there.
It has to go in there and try to fucking
find.
And why don't you just leave him?
Why did they,
why don't they just leave them down there?
What the fuck?
I don't understand.
You know what I mean?
Just fucking leave him down there.
Why do you get to spend all that money to go get a swim into a cave?
He went into a cave underwater.
Like,
what the fuck are we supposed to do?
And that's somebody,
God damn job,
they've got to go down and fish.
You going down there,
no one,
you're going to see a dead body when they find them.
I guess they always have this goofy smile on their face because the last thing
is your body releases.
I don't all this dopamine or some shit.
I've sound like Joe Rogan right now except I don't know what I'm talking about.
A dope mean and you know one of those drugs that those fucking ravers take
releases that shit.
Right.
And they feel this,
this level of euphoria,
like the nd your life level of euphoria.
And then the next day that just eating like a bowl of apple jacks and they did
like just burst out in tears because it's so fucking depressing cause they
fucked up.
They already know what it feels like,
the dive,
whichever Delhi after you go through the horror or blah blah blah blah under the
walker,
I guess it's a nice experience and be like,
hey man,
that was just that bad.
Um,
strive with x amount of my fucking mind.
I know what,
uh,
where we get 44 minutes,
44 fucking minutes.
Oh,
Jesus.
I used to go down here and I used to do hot 97,
you know,
back in the day when everything was fucking crazy,
like three times a year,
rappers would see they have like a gun battle and the fucking lobby.
And I would go down there whenever I was doing,
uh,
whenever I was doing Caroline's,
you know,
and I used to headline Carolines on like a Tuesday night and they would,
uh,
Louis Faranda used to have to pull the fucking curtain,
you know,
so wouldn't look bad.
And,
uh,
I was doing talents,
rums and a,
so let's do the white and the black room.
So I used to come down here and they used to try to get some people that maybe
saw me open,
fair,
a
talent or drew Frasier,
a fucking Gerald Kelly,
the New York kings.
MMM.
Rob Stapleton.
All of them ice do that rooms.
Uh,
one of the most fun times in my career that I had was,
was doing that stuff.
Uh,
nobody knew who the fuck I was.
I had to go on stage,
you know,
we expect now people come out,
they know who I am.
So then it's like I have to work to lose them.
Went back then I actually had to fucking earn it.
And uh,
you know,
believe me,
I,
I look back on those days fondly,
but I don't,
I don't miss nuts selling tickets.
So whenever I come back here,
I always think about all of those gigs.
Um,
Capone used to have this room Nell's on 14th street and it was the greatest
fucking bar,
but it was such a hard room for me that one in Labar bet talent had that one and
that one,
that fucking room,
every time I went there,
it was like I bombed.
Next time I killed,
I bombed,
I killed.
And I,
I could never figure that roadmap was like an after work party.
And I used to go up there white as hell.
And it just,
either they,
you know,
you had basically in the black rooms you have,
you have your opening joke and then that's it.
They black people had,
they're very much like Sicilian.
Swear it,
it's like you're dead to them.
You fuck up once that's it.
You dead to me over there's,
there's this relationship is done and there's no,
there's no,
uh,
there's no repairing it.
Um,
which is why it's amazing what's her face.
The Fuji Chick there started to get booed on the Apollo and then fucking turned
it around.
The hell's her God damn name.
You know,
amazing voice.
Cute.
Is Health four hours late to her shows.
Lauren Hill.
Um,
whenever I hear the Fuji Music,
that reminds me when I first moved down here,
that uh,
Ooh,
tank claim 36 chambers.
And what else?
What else was I listening to back then?
I don't know.
Okay.
Now if this kind of driving like a fucking maniac,
I think he's sick of my podcast here.
Um,
how far away are we?
Another five minutes.
You know,
they're freaking out,
man.
What the fuck is he going to a hotel?
Phone?
Yeah,
I got to,
I look like I look like I just came from Saskatchewan and they're going to take
pictures so I can't be looking like that.
I got to look like a,
at least bathe today.
Um,
ah dude,
I had fucking 6:30 AM flight today.
Uh,
not that puts me in a goddamn mood.
My show didn't get done until 12,
and of course I had to go out and have a couple of pops to celebrate the end of
the tour.
Um,
I want to thank everybody who would seriously,
who came out in Winnipeg.
Everybody that came out and uh,
tube saskatoons sorry about the pop it on the piece here and uh,
everybody that came out,
Regina,
I had a great time.
I'm definitely,
those three cities are now part of my tours.
Um,
now I,
I feel I can go right across the whole southern part.
So I was telling people the next thing I'm going to do is I'm going to do to
Alaska over the yellow knife and some other ones.
Jesus Christ,
fucking nine foot lady with no clothes on.
And you see that
she had her ass hanging out of the bottom of her fucking dress
like a sand trap.
Somebody fucking divots in it.
Sorry,
sorry.
I'm sorry.
I'm not that,
that many price.
And we stopped to get gas.
No,
he's trying to make a left there.
Oh,
okay.
Sorry.
Yeah,
let's go.
Let's go.
Okay.
We get behind the one polite cab driver in the fucking city here.
Yeah.
Why these people wearing scarves?
It's not even cold out.
Absolutely.
Absolutely not.
Exactly
right.
You mean the left we'll go left to right
at idiot.
Yeah.
I like your meal like me.
You just shit on everybody's,
you're driving then moron.
So,
right.
They don't leave.
Especially if it's Sunday you got,
he's like forensic.
Jurassic Park comes out.
Forgive me if you want.
I love what you say and Trashmore of a Mig and more entertaining.
It makes me feel more normal cause that's all I do.
Don't you think part of it is because we feel like,
you know,
they don't know what we're doing.
We're too wrapped up in ourselves or do you think they're morons
when you arrived and,
and none of the 99 people is wrong.
That makes you weird.
Right?
There you go.
Yeah,
that makes you right.
I love it.
I'll look at that.
Bill's Barn Burger.
Oh and there's some flyer fan in there with a closure roof.
Claude [inaudible] fucking name.
I said,
oh,
okay.
Right here.
All right dude.
I'm going to jump out and I'll be around.
All right.
I'm just going to,
I'm going to,
I'll be cool.
I'll be back down in like,
I'll be so good at,
cause I don't think there's a place for me.
Do you have to circle?
I think you've got my phone number.
I just,
I think the text.
Did you text me?
Let me call you now.
Call me now.
So then I got it.
Then you call me.
I was showing him the front.
Okay,
cool.
All right.
You know what?
I'm going to call these people and I'll let them know that I'm coming over.
I Dunno.
What?
Why the fuck do I have to be there an hour early for a Goddamn podcast?
Like a warm up my voice.
Fuck,
fuck,
fuck shit.
Right.
Um,
it's my phone ringing.
No,
that's not me.
Somebody saying hello.
Unless we're in that fucking movie with the guy from Beretta.
You ever see that movie?
The guy who killed somebody or maybe killed somebody got out of jail.
He played Beretta remembered the,
they call them the guy who did like twin peaks or something.
Come on.
You know that not Mulholland drive.
What's the,
what's the,
you remember the guy from bread?
I don't go to bed with a price on your head.
No,
I'm gonna call you.
Don't do it.
All right.
Why don't you just give me your phone and I'll do it.
I don't say my number here now.
It's not three one.
Oh,
come here.
Just give me the Goddamn.
Why do you have one glove on?
Unless you drive and glove and I,
Michael Jackson that I knew when I use the left hand moves
right with Michael Jackson.
I love it.
You Beg,
you got frame.
You got Frank.
You know something.
I actually think he did too.
You know what?
Yeah.
You can't fucking molest a bunch of white kids even if you became white.
Yeah,
and get off on it twice.
But California couldn't,
they couldn't nail down Oj.
Right.
They just want to do a one is the reputation that they just want you to.
All right.
Having said that,
would you leave,
would you,
would you if you had a kid,
I don't know.
If you have kids you wouldn't leave and with Michael though,
right?
Okay.
Now they're all day cause they could fight them off.
I'm going to park on that side so you can feel free to take all your time.
I'll be right here.
He just pull up to your house,
right?
Stomping his foot.
Then your fucking kids got to go up.
All right.
I got to hit pause on this.
I'll do the last eight minutes later.
All right.
Backs.
Do I need to what?
Pack your bag.
Oh yeah.
That's where my,
that's where my show closer.
All right.
Let me help you that.
Yeah,
there's like regular clothes and then this headlining clothes.
I've got to get on my head.
Planning.
Okay.
All right.
I'll talk to you.
It's in a minute.
All right.
I'm back.
Oh,
for freckled Foucault is back here.
I did all my breasts that I had to
do.
I want to thank everybody over at vulture fest.
Everybody treated me great.
I had a fun time going back and forth.
One of the women over there was giving me shit about how bad the Celtics were
playing and uh,
you know,
and I was just agreeing with her and then she just kept trying to do a dig on
the Celtics and I go,
you know,
I really don't appreciate you.
A little passive aggressive comments on the Celtics.
I'm admitting that you're kicking our ass.
And then she laughed,
gone,
ah,
you caught the,
so I go,
you know what part of Ohio you're from?
I mean,
she goes,
oh,
I'm not from Ohio.
I go,
wait a minute,
you know,
from Ohio,
how are you a Cavaliers fan?
She goes,
I'm a Lebron Fan,
and like,
get the fuck out.
And she goes,
yeah,
no,
I was a fan of his when he went down to Miami.
And I'm a fan now that he's gone back to Cleveland.
He's just like,
you know,
find out she's from Washington DC.
I'm like,
you're a fucking wizards fan.
She goes,
Ooh,
I don't want to do that.
It's just,
you know what,
I actually respect it on some level.
I think that she's a,
uh,
you know,
if,
I guess if they're all going to be free agents and piling on with each other,
then you might as well be like a free agent fence,
then it doesn't fucking matter.
Right.
I Dunno.
I Dunno what was pulled out.
I'm just joking around.
We had a great time giving each other shit and then I got to sit down.
They,
um,
it was pretty cool.
They actually showed the first episode of season two and from what I heard,
people really liked it.
I,
of course was not in the room.
I didn't want to deal with that.
And,
um,
and then we went and we did a,
uh,
I went in,
I did it the interview in front of the crowd that just saw it and a handed out
some free tee shirts.
We had these,
these condoms made up is for family condoms and stuff.
Handed them out.
People like those took some pictures afterwards is great interview,
you know,
just great questions.
And that type of thing was a lot of fun.
And uh,
knocked it out.
So,
oh Billy boy is going to be hitting the fucking hotel,
blah.
He assumed how much him I got left here.
I got a knock out.
Another fucking five minutes.
I might do it tomorrow morning.
Maybe I'll do that.
You know,
cause it doesn't make a difference because you guys,
I got to watch the Celtics man.
How much are they down by?
All right.
Watch I even how to turn on a TV anymore.
Watch now.
Yes.
That's what I want to do.
I want to watch now.
You want to watch?
I want to watch TV.
Setting the world on fire.
How much are we down by Kelly Olynyk for the love of God.
Pretend it's fourth quarter game seven.
Whatever the fuck it is you have to do.
All right,
come on.
this is football.
You guys really going to listen to me channel stuff.
You don't really hear this shit.
I'm going to watch the God damn game and I know dude live commentate 11 not
doing that.
So I'm gonna just sit here watching these people get in.
The fucking shit kicked out of them.
Yeah.
Isaiah is out.
I mean we could potentially
that we could lose by 40.
Okay.
Oh my God.
All of a sudden just having the number one draft pick just seems a lot
different.
I knew all these fucking people going,
like,
I'll tell you right now,
the Celtics Arolio player way,
I was at least smart enough to say we're more like a player and a half away half
though it meaning we needed to players remember a few months ago where they were
trying to suggest if we got Carmelo Anthony like we'd have a legitimate shot to
take out.
Fucking,
I almost said the Lebron James,
the Cavaliers.
But that's really what it is.
Um,
I don't think we do this and I'm going to watch this game.
This podcast is going to be like,
I owe you three minutes.
Okay.
I really don't because I've done a bunch of that over an hour,
but um,
I got to upload the shit.
I got an early flight cause I got to go out and,
uh,
get back to my wife and daughter.
That's it.
Thank you guys for listening.
And please tell everybody on May 30th thatF is for family is coming out and I'm
going to be doing a bunch of press.
So I apologize if you see my stupid face,
a little bit too much out there.
I have to do it.
I got to put on the monkey sad monkey hat,
the little fucking,
you know,
do my little fucking dance and a over the next couple of weeks.
But um,
you know,
I'm going to be trying to,
I don't know.
I'll Bobby trying to let you guys know where I'm going to be at.
If you give a shit.
All right,
that's it.
Go fuck yourselves and I'll check in on you on Thursday.